the jurogan experience well
what you said made me think of one of
the hardest stories i ever did
i did a an article for the new yorker
about the
sons of jim jones oh and uh
not everybody died in jonestown uh
he had three sons two of them were
adopted and
they were playing a basketball
tournament in georgetown gianna
and um this this story took place when i
you remember the branch davidians yeah
now that you're a texan you know just up
the road yeah
uh my editor at the new yorker at the
time was tina brown and she uh
she asked me to go you know write about
the branch davidians
and i said tina there are more reporters
than branch davidians up there right now
i couldn't
you know but what i was had been
watching the news coverage and just
before
the place was called rancho apocalypse
which is turned out to be really
appropriate
but they sent before the conflagration
they sent out a van
with children you know who had grown up
in this community
and these kids you know as they they
drove past the atf and the fbi lines and
in the media line and you could see
these children
looking out the windows they were
leaving behind
everybody they knew they were leaving
behind the only world they knew
and they were going into what and i
thought
what happened to those kids this must
have happened you know what will happen
to those it must have happened to
children
elsewhere and so i started doing some
investigation and i found out that
you know jones had these three kids
three young boys they were well they
were young men
um and there was jim jr who was
black uh and then there was stephen
and uh who was the natural son and there
was tim jones
and um
for whatever reason they hadn't talked
to anybody and they agreed to talk to me
wow uh and perhaps it
had to do with you know the branch
davidian thing that was going on at that
same time
so this was in the early 90s yeah it was
15 years after jonestown
it was actually almost exactly 15 years
and there's a
cemetery in oakland where
many of most of the 900 bodies were
buried and there's
they took a earth mover and
and took a hill down you know half of a
hill
and then they stacked all the caskets up
and covered again
but it still has this distortion and you
can see
you know what remained of the the
jonestown
followers but it was interesting to me
that
the people who joined the jones
cult were all good people
they were all you know it was started in
indianapolis and then it moved to the
bay area
and it was largely a you know largely
black
jones was uh very very progressive you
know on race
and uh but you know a lot of good
hearted people involved in it
and he was a a big figure in san
francisco at the time politically
you know his his support was sought
after you know he was admired as a
community leader but he was
totally crazy and paranoid and suddenly
decided he had to remove
the entire group and you can't tell your
family you know you can't tell anybody
you were
going just to you know he sent his sons
down to guiana to clear the
jungle so they could make this village
and uh
and then overnight they move you know
nearly a thousand people
to south america and leaving behind
all their friends their jobs and stuff
like that one day you know they've
they've been you know removed they've
been uh
raptured you know off to south america
and so i was
interested you know that you know
learning more about it but
uh these these
you know young men were totally haunted
but you would you would certainly relate
to tim
jones he was physically one of the
very powerful you know he curled you
know 100 pounds with either
hand you know he but he couldn't
he couldn't get on an elevator uh
the last time he tried to do an airplane
flight i mean this had been years ago i
don't know if it's changed for him now
but
he was he made the airplane turn
around and drop him off at the gate
which is hard to do but when you're
you know as physically overpowering as
tim was
you know he's a he's kind of a
formidable figure
and so he just had all sorts of
anxieties so
i went to talk to him and
he he said i'll do it on one condition
we have to do it in a public place you
know a restaurant
someplace where i won't cry and i want
my wife there because i never told her
about it
and wow it's a little hard for me to
tell this story because
we went to a restaurant and within
five minutes he was crying you know and
pounding the
table and the waiter was keeping his
distance people in the restaurant were
you know
frightened and he told the story of
going back he's the one who had to
identify
900 people his
his natural birth parents his adopted
parents
he had a wife and children then too they
were all dead
everybody was dead and
i've never forgotten the power
of of a religious belief in a
personality like jim
jones who could persuade all those
people
to stay with him train them in this you
know
suicide drills night after night you
know and then one day it's real
and you know the boys
felt guilty because they thought if they
had been there
they might have been able to stop it but
probably not catch new episodes of the
joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify you can listen to
the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience